>>Jen Clark: Hello everyone.
Welcome.
Thanks for
coming.
I'm really happy about today.
My name is Jen
Clark.
I'm from the benefits team.
I work on the OYL
program.
This is part of the health@speaker series
which
is aimed at providing information to Googlers
about health
and wellness topics.
I've got a slide up there that tells you a
little bit more.
We welcome your feedback on any these topics.
So if you have
some, please feel free to goto/health@survey.
For more
information on OYL, please check out and goto/OYL.
And
if you're interested in planning and being
involved in these types of talks,
please check out goto/wellnesschampions.
And I'm particularly excited because Brandon
was a school
classmate of mine at the Stanford Graduate
School of
Business about four, five years ago.
And he's now taking
his experience as a physician and as someone
with business
training in exploring ways to use business
and health
together.
So I'm really excited to have him here.
A
little bit background on Brandon.
Doctor Brandon Colby
is a world leader in the field of predictive
medicine, a
groundbreaking medical specialty that combines
comprehensive genetic testing with personalized
prevention based upon your genes.
Dr. Colby has been
involved in the genetics field for his entire
life, first
as a patient then as a researcher and now
as a practicing
physician.
He has conducted extensive research in the
field of advanced clinical genetic analysis,
inventing numerous
patent-pending technologies that make comprehensive
genetic screening
understandable, useful, and empowering to
both the
physician and the patient.
Dr. Colby is also the only
practicing physician in the world to have
designed a
first of its kind DNA chip which I believe
you all will
see later.
In addition to serving as the medical
director of the Existence Health, a predictive
medicine private practice based
in Los Angeles, Dr. Colby is also the founder
and CEO of
his Existence Genetics, a company that provides
highly
advanced predictive medicine services to the
health
industry.
He holds a degree in genetics from the
University of Michigan honors program, an
M.D. from the
Mount Sinai school of medicine and an MBA
from the Stanford
Graduate School of Business.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Colby.
[Applause]
>>Dr. Colby: Thank you, Jen.
Today is an incredibly
important day for our civilization.
And it's important
because we stand right at the point of transition
between
the age of information and the age of personalization.
We're moving from this information age where
we now have
an unprecedented amount of access to information.
Basically, our world's accumulated information
as
knowledge accessible to anyone and any time
from anywhere
for practically no cost.
And we're moving from access to
this information from this generic information
to now
personalizing it and making it about a unique
person --
about each of us in unique ways.
And the fundamental
underpinning of how information is made to
be
personalized on how each of us is unique is
our genes.
And that's what I'm going to talk about today
-- gaining
access to our genes through genetic testing,
understanding what that means, and then using
that
information to personalize products and services.
Since
I'm a doctor, I'm going to talk about how
we can use that
information to personalize health care.
This is
applicable to really any product and service
that we
could think of.
And in the future, we're going to start
to see a genetically-tailored world that all
products and
services are going to start to be tailored
to our genes.
They're going to be personalized.
So to begin, I'm going
to walk you through an example that we're
all going to
participate in.
For some of you, it may help to close
your eyes.
For others, let's just imagine that we're
standing in a darkroom.
And the room is so dark, we
can't even see our hand in front of our face.
All of a
sudden, we feel something come up and kick
us in the back
of the leg.
We turn around, we try to defend ourselves,
but we can't, because we don't know what's
attacking us,
we don't know when it's going to come again
and we feel
something go and punch us in the stomach.
We try to
defend ourselves again and we can't and again
we get hit
in the head.
Now, I know this seems like an awkward
situation, but this is actually the current
state of
health care that we're in practically the
dark ages.
We
don't know what diseases may lay ahead.
We don't know what
we may be faced with and we don't know when
they may come
and attack us.
Now, imagine that we're back in that room
again, it's very dark, we can't see, and somebody
places something into our hands, a tool.
But we don't
know whether that tool is going to help us,
whether we'll be
able to use that tool to defend ourselves
or potentially that tool is going to harm
us.
And that's the
current state of many of the treatments that
we receive, a lot of the medications that
are prescribed to us.
We don't know if
they're going to be effective.
We don't know if they're
potentially going to harm us.
And the person who hands
you that tool in that room is your doctor,
your
physician.
And their eyesight--.
Our eyesight is not
much better than yours.
That we can't really make out
what's ahead.
We use family history to try to guess at
what diseases you may be predisposed to.
We ask you
questions like, "have you ever had a an allergic
reaction
before?"
To try to guess at medications that we don't
want to give you.
But other than that, our eyesight is
really not much better.
We can make out shadows, but we
don't really know what is there.
We don't know what
diseases lay ahead for you.
And because of that, we
can't really prevent anything from coming
and attacking
you.
Now, we talked about this model, so health
care in terms of
being in the dark ages.
What predictive medicine does,
which is combining genetic testing with the
personalized
prevention of disease is, it turns the light
on.
It
allows us, through genetic testing, to examine
an
individual's genes to see what diseases they
may be
predisposed to.
And then to add preventions before those
diseases ever manifest.
So it's turning the light on in
the room, allowing us to see what's lurking
in those
shadows, allows us to best take preemptive
measures, to
either prevent that disease from ever attacking
us.
Or if
we see it coming towards us because that light
now is on
in the room, we could take steps to make sure
that it has
the smallest amount of impact upon us as possible.
And
also genetic testing allows us to know whether
medications, whether certain treatments, even
lifestyle
modifications as we'll discuss, whether those
will help
slow down or prevent disease.
So, we're moving now from
standing in this very dark room to turning
on the light.
To be able to turn on the light through genetic
testing
and predictive medicine.
So let's move on to the next example and actually
walk
through a person's life and see how this could
impact
somebody today.
Because everything we're going to
discuss in this entire talk is possible today.
So let's
say today a baby is born.
Baby Emily.
She's born
completely healthy, lives a normal childhood,
teenage years,
no problem.
She gets through her 20s.
She's fine.
She
turns 30.
She begins to start a family and all of a
sudden she goes and has a massive heart attack.
She's in
the intensive care unit for about two weeks
and then
unfortunately she dies.
Now, her parent -- I'm sorry --
her physicians did absolutely nothing wrong.
So the
physicians practice medicine as they're taught.
That
they treated her like a generic patient.
Throughout her
teenage years, throughout her 20s, hardly
ever does a
doctor closely examine somebody's heart, because
most
people that age -- their hearts are fine.
But Emily is
unique as most of us are.
She was unique.
She contained
genes that were predisposing her to early
onset heart
attack and her doctors just had no idea.
They were
standing in that dark room.
And that's why a heart
attack was able to go and manifest.
Her cholesterol built up.
It was never detected and she had that heart
attack.
So
now we have tremendous heartache.
Her family has lost a
loved one.
We have doctors who were powerless to protect
their patient's life.
And we also have society that now
has spent a tremendous amount of money on
this ICU care
in the intensive care unit and lost a productive
member
of their community at the end.
So let's say slightly
different scenario.
Emily is in the intensive care unit.
She's able to be saved and her doctors go
and prescribe a
medication.
A medication that they give to a lot of
people in this situation.
And they treat Emily again
like a generic patient.
They start her at 5 milligrams.
Everybody who receives this blood thinner
receives it at
5 milligrams.
And most of us are used to that.
When our
doctor prescribes us medications, it's at
the same dose
that you know they've given to the last person
and
they'll give to the next person.
But, for Emily, she's
extremely sensitive to this medication.
Her doctors
had no idea.
They didn't want to cause any harm, but
they thinned her blood so much with that 5
milligrams
that she ended up bleeding into her brain
and she died
again.
So again, we have the loss of life, we have
the
heartache and we have the loss to society
in terms of
spending a tremendous amount of money and
now actually
causing more harm than good.
So now, the model of
predictive medicine -- of using genetic testing
-- to
predict disease.
We could go all the way to when Emily
is born.
Genetic testing is so simple now, doesn't
even
require any blood.
So her parents choose to have genetic
testing for Emily.
They collect some of her saliva with
her pediatrician.
They send that for testing and analysis, which
we'll talk about later.
And the doctor gets back the
report and sees that Emily contains genes
that predispose
her to early onset heart attack.
And again, this is
possible now.
So the doctor makes note of that.
There's
not much to be done right at that age when
she's a baby,
but when she enters her teenage years, her
doctors do
something differently.
They start to pay attention to
her heart, because that light has been turned
on in the
room.
They know heart disease is lurking in the
shadows.
So they start doing blood tests, they start
monitoring
her cholesterol levels.
Different biomarkers.
And when she gets
to about 18 or 19, they see that her cholesterol
levels
start to go up.
So the doctors go and work with her --
go over her genetic report in terms of lifestyle
modifications.
Let's not start medications right now,
they say.
Let's focus on lifestyle modifications.
They're able to go tailor her cardiovascular
exercise to
her genes.
So that she's able to optimize what are going
to be the most effective exercises for her.
They're also
able to go and start to tailor some of her
nutrition.
So
they talk about some of the generic things
we're told in terms of
low fat diet, staying away from refined sugars.
But they
also tell her based upon her genetic profile,
eating a
specific type of vegetable, cruciferous vegetables,
are
likely to be beneficial to her in cutting
down her heart
attack risk.
And they also see from her genetic report
that she's likely not to like the taste of
these
vegetables.
Based upon taste bud genes, those vegetables
are likely to taste really bitter to her.
So they tell her
different methods to still eat those vegetables
but avoid
that bitter taste such as mixing them with
other foods.
So as you see they're completely tailoring
these
lifestyle recommendations to her genes to
make them as
effective as possible.
So now Emily is able to go and
integrate this into her lifestyle.
She slows down the
progression of disease significantly.
But then in her
mid 30s, her doctors are still conscientiously
monitoring
her blood.
They see her cholesterol levels increasing
again.
So at that time, her doctors say, "all right,
we
have to go and start integrating some medications."
The
genes were -- we were able to slow down the
process but
now we need medications.
We need something stronger.
So
you look at the genetic profile that was taken
when Emily
was just a child.
And they see that she's very sensitive
to a medication they're about to prescribe.
So instead
of giving 5 milligrams, they give 0.5 milligrams.
Emily
is able to avoid a heart attack.
She's able to raise a
family, have grandchildren, and live a full
life.
Now
the doctors are able to focus in on what's
important for
Emily and also provide the most effective
preventions and
treatments.
So they've been a success, too.
And now our
society has gained a productive member of
the community
throughout her entire life.
And they focus all their
health care spending on that which matters
most and that which is going to be most
effective.
So that is what genetic testing now allows
--
it allows us to go turn on that light for
health care.
It
allows us to move from our current model of
health care,
which is really more like sick care.
Most of us just
wait until we get sick and then we see a doctor.
We wait
for a disease to occur and then we go and
we diagnose and
doctors hope that they could treat.
But what this new
model -- this genetic testing, this personalization
of healthcare -- allows us to do is actually
go and move to a different paradigm where
we focus on the
proactive personalized prevention of disease
throughout a
person's life.
Now, we've been talking about genetic
testing.
It's a bit nebulous to people in terms of
what
exactly genetic testing is.
And genetic testing is
really a generic term people use to refer
to three things
or three components of genetic technology.
The first is
testing, so that's the acquisition of raw
data.
The
second is analysis, or clinical analysis,
that's
transitioning that data, translating it from
this raw
data to an actionable information state.
And the third
is reporting.
It's actually delivering that to the end
user.
We'll talk about each one of those now.
So the
first component -- just get to the slide -- [pause]
okay great, thank
you.
So the first component is testing.
And testing is
acquiring all the raw data -- all the letters
of our
genetic code.
And this involves a lot of hardware.
So
it involves laboratory function.
And I'm going to talk
about two other types of technology that allows
us to
undergo this genetic testing.
Let's take a step back and
think about where genetic testing was about
ten years ago.
So
ten years ago to look at one single gene may
have cost 5,
10, even 20,000 dollars and it would have
taken months
for that to be turned around.
And almost always, you had
to go and give blood; so it was invasive.
Now with this
new technology that we'll discuss first, -- called
a DNA chip
or microarray -- that's a generic term.
Now with this new
technology, we don't have to look at just
one gene.
We
can look at thousands of genes all at the
same time for
just a few hundred dollars.
So it's been a major
inflection point in terms of how much we're
able to do
for much more cost effective price point.
And also all
we have to do right now is really use saliva.
We do not
need to use blood anymore.
So it's become non-invasive.
And this is a picture of one type of gene
chip, of a DNA
chip.
This is the one that I spent about six years
creating called the Nexus DNA chip.
This is the actual
chip itself.
So one of these is used to process 12
different samples.
And you could come up and take a look
at this after, but this is just so that you
guys have an
idea of the scale that it's quite small.
And what this
does is, it allows us to look at thousands
of genes all at
the same time.
And it skips over all of the irrelevant
information.
So this is one gene.
And you could think
of all the letters -- so all those are different
GPS
coordinates.
And only those that are in red are known to
be associated with some clinical state.
They have some
relevancy.
All the other data is just extraneous.
Even
if we had it, we wouldn't do anything with
it.
So what a
DNA chip allows us to do is hone in -- zero
in -- on
those that are red and test those in the individual.
So we're
testing several different letters in one gene.
Then we
move on to the next gene and the next and
the next.
So
we're skipping over all that is superfluous.
We're
focusing in on that which is most important.
Now, the Nexus DNA chip is
important for predictive medicine purposes.
There are
different chips out there.
This one is specific for
really protecting a person's health, for preventing
disease risk and then finding out what's really
going to
be the most effective preventions.
And this has really
unlocked this new era -- this genetic revolution.
Our
ability to move towards personalization because
of this
technology which is just a few hundred dollars.
Now,
there's a new technology that's currently
in development.
It's moving along quite rapidly called whole
genome
sequencing.
Many of us are probably familiar with the
human genome project.
That took about ten years.
It was
completed in 2003.
And it cost about 3 billion dollars
to accomplish.
Required an international team of
scientists.
So 2003, 3 billion dollars.
And that
was all to sequence a single person.
And whole genome
sequencing mean you're getting 6 billion letters
per
person.
So the DNA chip may acquire tens of thousands
to
millions of letters.
This new technology requires every
single letter.
So it acquires both the black and the
red.
It doesn't distinguish.
It just gets the entire
sequence.
And that's 6 billion letters per person.
So
what costs 3 billion dollars and took ten
years and ended
in 2003 today could be done for 4,000 dollars
and takes
about a month.
That's projected to come down quite
rapidly all the way to 500, 100 dollar mark
and soon
under a day, maybe even an hour where we're
able to go
accumulate all this data.
As we see from the DNA chip
where it's getting tens of thousands to millions
of relevant data points
to whole genome sequencing that getting 6
billion, it's
an avalanche of data.
So tremendous amount of raw data
we have to deal with right now.
And that's where the
next component comes in that's clinical analysis.
So
that's why moving from testing to analysis
is really
important.
And we'll talk about that in a moment.
But
first, how relevant is whole genome sequencing
to us?
And this chart shows the decreasing cost.
So the lines
that are in red and black and green are different
costs
of this technology of whole genome sequencing.
The line
that's in blue is a number of people who have
had their
genome sequenced.
Number of just individuals.
So by the
end of this year we'll be somewhere around
50,000; it's
projected to be around that.
And we think to about 2014
or so we're looking at closer to 10 to 100
million.
We
look at 2020, we're looking at close to a
billion
genomes.
A billion people having their entire sequence
deduced.
So a billion people and 6 billion letters
per
person.
So it's just a tremendous avalanche of data.
And now, the question arises, "What do we
do with all
that data?
How do we make sense of that?"
And that's
really what my team and I specialize in.
It's clinical
analysis and reporting of this tremendous
amount of raw
data that's now able to be accumulated using
this new
technology.
And what clinical analysis does is, it
translates the data from just raw data into
actionable
meaningful information.
It allows value to be attributed
to them.
Because without analysis, all those letters
of
a person's genome are really nothing more
than a
high-tech paper weight.
That's -- it's not even a paper
weight because you can fit that on a small
thumb drive.
So
it's quite light.
None of that is important to a
person's health unless that data is translated
into
information.
I'm going to go through one example of a
clinical analysis technology just so that
you have some
idea of what I'm talking about when I refer
to analysis.
Let's think back to the baby Emily example
that she has
genetic testing, she's found to be at increased
risk of a
heart attack, then I also mention that different
medications are analyzed.
So that means that different
genes are looked at after a heart attack risk
is
detected.
Different genes are analyzed in relation to
different preventions and treatments associated
with
heart attack.
Different lifestyle modifications -- like
the cruciferous vegetables and whether that
taste that
Emily is going to enjoy the taste or not,
those genes are
analyzed.
So it's a whole another set, all different
sets of genes are then analyzed after that
initial center
node, that center disease.
And we could see a flowchart
here that goes first rounds, a risk of heart
attack is
deduced.
Then the reflex analysis comes in.
This is all
software based, so we move from the testing
which is
hardware to now the clinical analysis which
is software.
So the software is doing this and it's programmed
specifically to be able to do this analysis.
It moves
from this first round to this second round
which looks at
different medications whether they're going
to be
effective, whether somebody is going to be
sensitive to
them.
It also looks at lifestyle modifications.
We
could even now start to provide someone information
whether surgery -- like a coronary artery
bypass graft-- is
going to be effective or not.
That's still in the
preliminary stages while these other information
now is
in the much more advanced stage.
And then the third
round of analysis we could go even deeper.
So we could
start to look at specific dosing for some
of the
medications.
That where we look at whether the person is
going to like the taste of vegetables.
Look at things that
are associated with exercise.
Reflex analysis really
goes as deep as needed in order to get all
of these
reflexes -- all of these different sets of
genes
analyzed.
And the whole purpose is to make that analysis
now integrated, which makes it much more actionable.
And
we'll see that as it's presented in the genetic
report in
a few minutes.
And this allows us to analyze a
tremendous amount of data all at once, so
all together.
Instead of thinking about it in a 2-dimensional
way, this
allows us to analyze things 3-dimensionally.
And this is
computer software that we created to enable
this reflex
analysis.
So that enables us to go and set up these
types of
reflexes, underlying each of the nodes that
you see is a
whole set of diseases, whole sets of algorithms
for
traits or medications or conditions.
But this allows us
our IT system to know to analyze one then
to reflex to
another one and then potentially another one
and another
one.
So we've talked about testing.
So the acquiring
the raw data.
And we talked about analysis -- moving
that data into useful, understandable information.
And
the third part is really key.
Because without proper
reporting, that testing which may be extremely
accurate
and the analysis which may be beautiful, without
proper
reporting, then it's all useless.
It's all wasted.
The
end-user can't easily understand what that
data means and
can't integrate that beneficially into their
lives, then
all that usefulness is lost.
The third step is
reporting.
And there are many different types of report
formats out there.
One is not better than the other.
It's just really dependent upon what you,
the end-user,
wants to get out of genetic testing.
So I'm going to go
over one of the types of reports.
This is the report
that my team and I have come up with over
the past five
years.
But it's just as important to note that there
are
many different types of report formats that
are out there now.
So this is a report format for heart attack
risk.
This
is the actual report that's printed.
So this is
delivered -- it would be delivered let's say
to Emily's
pediatrician.
And this is a report page that talks about
heart attack.
It's actually two pages because there's so
many medications now associated with heart
disease that
we could provide information about when we
do genetic
testing.
So right at the top, we see three gauges.
The
gauge right in the center is risk.
So this person is at
high risk.
And it says specifically about 67 percent
risk.
We like to focus more on the qualitative on
these
zones.
So they're in the zone of high risk.
And that is
based upon analysis many different genes.
And it's also
compared right below it to what's called generic
population risk.
That's the everyday risk for a person
if they have no idea what their genes contain.
It's just
taken off of mass population studies and say
how many
people around this age with this ethnicity
with this
gender are likely to have this disease?
And for heart
attacks, for a Caucasian male, it's around
47%
lifetime risk.
For this person based upon their genes,
it's closer to 70 percent risk.
So they're at high risk.
Now there are two other gauges.
A gauge on the left is
the clinical significance gauge.
And that's there so
that a person understands, "is this information
even
relevant to their health?"
Because there's some diseases
or conditions that they may be really at high
risk for
but it's not going to impact them significantly,
it's not
going to cause them a lot of harm, it's not
going to be something
they have to focus on or worry about.
So if in the report,
there are some things that are very high clinical
significance high risk.
And there are other things that
are very low clinical significance but high
risk.
They
know to focus on the ones that are more significant.
They know -- they're able to differentiate
and their
health care provider is able to differentiate
also and
say, "okay.
This one is much more important.
Let's
focus on this."
And for heart attack, it's very
significant to somebody's health.
If somebody has a
heart attack, they could die, which is why
it has high
clinical significance.
Now, the last gauge and one on the
right is actionability.
So even if somebody comes back
at high risk for something and it's very clinically
significant and there's low actionability,
there's
nothing that could be done about it, then
again what's the
point?
So we really focus on the conditions, diseases
that have either moderate or high actionability.
So
actionability means that we can implement
preventions
such as lifestyle modifications, medications,
complementary medicine therapies and even
different
screening exams.
We could implement these and either
prevent the disease outright or slow it down
significantly so that it manifests much later.
And that
physicians now know to be on the lookout for
these so
that it's detected at its earliest stages
and able to be
treated much more effectively.
So that's the
actionability gauge.
Now, about 60 percent of this heart
attack page is devoted to actionability to
actually
describing, "what can be done with this information?"
So
that gauge says actionability is high.
Now what do we do
with that in order to make it actionable?
And that's a
section that we call genetically tailored
prevention.
So
this is prevention where many of the recommendations
here
are based on a person's genes.
And we see in the
lifestyle modifications one -- the second
from the last
bullet point -- is that cruciferous vegetable
example that we
talked about with Emily.
And there are other
recommendations within this genetically tailored
prevention section that is on the screen now
that are
based upon an analysis of a person's genes
using reflex analysis.
So we
see now through the testing-acquired data,
the analysis
analyzed it in this integrated way and the
reporting is
able to present it in a very integrated way
that makes
for a rapid understanding and very easy for
a person to
go and integrate this into their life and
to benefit from
this information as well as their health care
provider to
use this information to change their clinical
management
and really provide much more personalized
services.
So
what we've seen now that genetic technology
-- there's
three components.
The testing, the analysis, and the
reporting.
Now where can you get genetic testing?
Let's
say you're interested in genetic testing.
Where can you
go to actually access your genes and to learn
what can
you do to protect your health?
And there are many
different places.
So the first is the Internet.
You can
go and have Direct to Consumer genetic testing.
Which
means you don't need a professional involved.
You can go to a website.
You could pay for a service
that they will send you the collection kit
just for
saliva.
You send them back some of your saliva and
in
about three or four weeks you get your results
online.
Now, the other way to get it is through a
health care
professional or health and wellness organization.
And
there's no right way or wrong way.
It's really based
upon your personal preference, what you feel
is best for
yourself and what you hope to get out of this
testing
process.
So you could also go through your doctor who
could go and perform this testing, collect
the saliva,
receive the report and then work with you
to integrate
that information into your clinical care so
that it
changes the way they're providing their care
and also
they're able to counsel you on that information
so that
you know what's best to integrate into your
lifestyle and
into your daily habits.
Now, part of that also is health
and wellness organizations.
So beyond just health care
providers, health and wellness organizations,
like
nutritionists, weight loss centers and even
fitness
centers are starting to use genetic testing.
I'm going
to walk you through a process so you can understand
from
beginning to end what's involved when I say
genetic
testing.
So let's say you want genetic testing and
you're interested in having it through a health
and
wellness organization.
You can actually have genetic
testing now through Equinox Fitness.
Many of us are
familiar with equinox from Palo Alto on El
Camino Real.
So they are providing genetic testing services
for their trainers
and the genetic testing is meant to optimize
fitness and
also work to prevent some exercise-related
diseases and
conditions.
So your interested in genetic testing.
You go
to equinox.
You meet with one of their fitness coaches.
and you say you're interested in genetic testing.
You
talk about it with them.
And they provide you with the
saliva collection kit.
This is an actual saliva
collection kit.
So basically you just spit into this kit
and this thing goes to a laboratory where
it gets
processed on a DNA chip.
Then a report is generated.
This is one of the sample Equinox reports.
So the
report's generated and it contains information
that's
specific for the person who's ordering it.
So for a
fitness trainer, this really only contains
information
that's specific for them as a fitness trainer
that will
help them optimize your fitness and athletic
performance.
So they get this report back, they review
the report, and
they meet with you and they discuss ways that
they're
going to integrate into your fitness.
One of the ways is
that they see that you're predisposed to endurance-based
activities.
So while you may have been doing
power-based.
Power is high intensity for low durations
of time.
While you may have been doing that in the
past
and seeing limited gains, now you could focus
more on
what your genes are predisposing you for.
So you could
focus on low endurance which is less intensity
but longer
periods of time.
Instead of 10, 15 minutes intervals you're
working out,
doing cardiovascular exercise for 30,
45, 60 minute intervals.
So they're able now to tailor
and personalize their services to your genes.
But beyond
that, they also learn that you're predisposed
to
osteoporosis.
That's another page that's in here that
provides osteoporosis risk.
So while a lot of women go
and osteoporosis manifests around the time
of menopause.
So around 50s or late 50s.
The bone loss -- the thinning
of the bone that leads to osteoporosis -- it
starts in
their late 20s and early 30s.
So by learning about
osteoporosis risk, a trainer is able to identify
a person
who would benefit from resistance training.
So that's
doing more weight-bearing exercises and a
lot of women
who are in their teenage years and 20s and
30s, they
don't do any resistance training, or they
do it
sporadically.
Because they just want to focus on
cardiovascular exercise.
So now the trainer knows how
important it is for this specific person to
do weight
training.
And they counsel that person on the importance
of integrating weight training into their
exercise
regimen.
They integrate it into the training themselves.
And now, this person is able to go and fortify
their
bones, so strengthen their bones, especially
the ones in
the lower back, the hips, the wrists, the
upper arm.
Through specific exercises that they're now
doing with
their trainer throughout their 20s and 30s,
40s.
By the
time they get to their 50s, those bones are
fortified.
They're stronger.
And now osteoporosis won't occur for
decades.
So the trainer has actually helped that person
go and avoid osteoporosis by integrating in
exercises
that previously that person may have been
hesitant to do.
And that trainer may have said, "okay, I don't
want to
push this person because they seem to be more
focused on
cardiovascular exercise so I'll just go with
that."
So
it provides guidance.
Now, it also allows us to go and
take away certain exercises.
On the next page after
osteoporosis, it provides an analysis of arthritis
risk.
Arthritis, separately, it's analyzed in the
hips, knees, and the
wrists as well.
So, the genetic report comes back and
the fitness trainer sees that the person is
predisposed
to knee arthritis.
Very high risk of knee arthritis.
So
he starts to pull that person away from activities
that
have impact upon the knee.
Instead of telling that
person to jog, instead of saying it's all
right to go run
on that treadmill after we're done with our
session,
they're saying, "okay.
Now you have to avoid jogging.
You have to cut down the treadmill or exclude
that
totally.
Instead focus your cardiovascular exercise
on
elliptical, on biking or on swimming."
So osteoporosis
they're integrating in specific exercises.
Now they're
pulling away and they're changing around modifying
their
plan so that they're avoiding causing more
harm to this
individual.
So instead of that person growing up and by
the time they're 50, their knees are completely
gone and
by the time they're 55 or 60 they need a knee
replacement
surgery, now we're preserving that knee function.
We're
allowing that person to age healthy.
So that when they
get to their 50s, when they get to their 60s,
their knees
are in much better shape.
So that's how this information
is being used today by a health and wellness
organization, by Equinox So we've identified
a major
problem with our health care system that we're
in the
Dark Ages.
That we don't really know how to personalize
our services to the individual.
We're just treating
people as generic object.
But we also have a solution
which is genetic testing.
And through that solution
we're able to go and personalize the field
of health
care.
And the last question that arises is, "why
is this
important now?"
Why do you need this now?
And it's a
3-part answer.
The first is that we need to integrate
genetic testing and predictive medicine into
our health
care system now because our health care system
-- our
sick care system -- which is true of the entire
world, is
unsustainable.
It's no different than our reliance on
fossil fuels.
That we need to move to a new renewable,
sustainable model of fuel and we need to do
the same
thing with health care.
We need to find a new renewable,
sustainable model.
One that focuses not on the defensive
aspect of just treating disease once it occurs
but
instead on the proactive prevention of disease.
And
that's what genetic testing now allows.
So we can't wait
20 years.
We can't wait ten years.
Too much of the
world GDP of every single country is devoted
towards
health care costs.
It doesn't matter if the model is
American one or the Canadian or the one in
Europe.
It
doesn't matter what health care cost it is,
it's still a
tremendous portion of the GDP and it's only
skyrocketing.
So it's unsustainable.
And we need the new model and we
need to start enacting that now.
Because it's going to
take time for it to spread throughout medicine
for other
specialties to go and to adopt it.
That's why we have to
start now to save our entire health care system.
Now,
the second reason why we need this now is
to save
ourselves.
Now, prevention is most effective when it's
started early.
And we have extremely good tools now.
We
have excellent testing.
We have great analysis and we
have really amazing reporting.
So we have the tools now
to identify risk, to start preventions.
And the earlier
preventions are started, the more effective
they are in
preventing a disease.
As an example, a tragic example,
there was a high school basketball player
-- his name was
Wes Leonard -- earlier this year, he was playing
basketball.
He went out for the game-winning shot.
He
made the shot.
He won the game for his team.
He went in
the locker room.
He was celebrating.
This is a high
school basketball player.
Celebrating and all of a
sudden he collapses and he dies.
Upon autopsy, the
doctors find that he had a condition called
dilated
cardiomyopathy.
Now the doctors didn't do anything
wrong.
They didn't go and miss this.
It's just they
weren't looking for it.
They didn't know that in this
teenager, they had to go and assess his heart.
Because
the majority of teenagers, their hearts are
fine.
Doctors
don't worry about the heart until late 30s
or 40s even
50s.
But for Wes Leonard, he had a gene, he possibly
had
a gene -- they haven't done genetic testing
on him -- but
very likely this condition was caused by genetic
abnormality.
So he had this underlying condition,
dilated cardiomyopathy, that went undiagnosed.
And
that's what led to his death.
Now, I frequently test
patients for this condition and a large number
of other
preventable sudden cardiac death.
So I test them on a
genetic level using this Nexus DNA chip, using
just
saliva.
At the same time we're looking at all the
risks
for different types of cancers, heart disease.
We're
also looking at preventable causes of sudden
death.
Now
I've detected dilated cardiomyopathy in patients.
I've
detected other sudden death diseases that
are
preventable.
They all have complicated names like long
QT syndrome and hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
and
arrhythmogenic right ventricular dysplasia.
So I've detected these in people.
They go and they see a cardiologist and prevention.
It's
very simple preventions.
Usually just medications.
Low
cost medications are enacted.
And sudden death is
avoided.
So in Wes Leonard's case one thing that could
have saved him was if he had genetic testing.
As you see, It's not like he could have waited
for that.
One year, five years.
He needed it last year.
So this is not only applicable
to preventable sudden cardiac at the time,
it's also
applicable to all different types of cancer
from breast
cancer, colon cancer, prostate cancer, skin
cancer, such
as melanoma.
Applicable to heart disease.
It's even
applicable to Alzheimer's disease where we
have different
interventions we can enact throughout life
which has been
shown to decrease either the risk of that
disease or
greatly delay its onset.
So we have that ability today.
Now, the third reason why this is so important
-- why we
need this now -- is to save our future generations.
So
genetic testing now allows us to identify
what diseases
we carry in our genes.
And by "carry," I mean we may not
have that disease.
We most likely don't have that
disease.
We have no way of knowing that we carry it.
These are rare diseases.
Rare recessive diseases like
cystic fibrosis, Tay-Sach's disease, sickle
cell anemia.
So we have no idea that we may carry these
diseases, but
if we have a child with somebody who also
carries the
same disease, then there's a high likelihood
that the
child will have that disease.
That's why we see often
people will have a child and that child will
have a
disease and the parents will say, "I had no
idea that I
carried this.
It's never manifested in my family before.
This is the first time."
But through genetic testing, we
can now identify what diseases we carry.
And geneticists
postulate that each person probably carries
three or four
diseases.
Each of us in this room right now are carrying
three to four rare diseases.
Do you know which ones they
are?
Do you know your spouse -- that person you're
going
to have a child with -- also carries those
diseases.
Using
gene chip technology --so this Nexus DNA chip--
, at first we
could screen for a handful.
Now we could screen for
hundreds.
Just recently we enabled this to gene for
over
1,000 rare diseases.
Over 1,000 rare diseases all at the
same time.
So we could start to identify who's carrying
what disease.
Doesn't mean that anything's wrong with
the person.
It just means that now they could take
proactive steps to protect their future generations.
And
there are clear things they could do to protect
their
future generations from inheriting a deadly
disease if
both they carry it and a spouse or whoever
they're going to have a
child with also carries that disease.
So it allows us to
save our health care system, save ourselves,
and to save
future generations all today.
And this is all possible
because we have this inflection point with
the technology.
So the testing now has come down tremendously
in price.
It's unlocked a way to access all of our genes.
We have
ways to analyze and understand this, because
we have 30
years of research.
30 years of genetic research, of
looking at what genes are associated with
what disease.
But
up until this technology that research has
only been
relegated to the library.
It's been published then it
goes into the library and it's not in use.
But with this
technology now, we can move it out of the
library and we
can make it all about one single person -- and
that's
you.
Thank you.
Now, for some questions now?
Okay,
great
>>Male #1: I'm curious about the rate among
the
general population for which you think that
genetic
testing can uncover, I guess, traits where
there's
actionable advice for how to avoid disease.
Like in
the case of cardiovascular disease, it's my
understanding that there are some very rare
genetic
conditions that obviously it would be good
to test
for, but more commonly it seems to be lifestyle
factors that are responsible.
>>Dr. Colby: Right.
So there are two parts to that
question.
The question was asking about how many
really common diseases that we could do something
about can we test for now?
Is it only really just
rare diseases, possibly rare cardiovascular
diseases can we test for.
Are there really the common ones that we
could learn something about and have that
be
actionable?
And the answer is, there are actually a
large number right now that we can test for
that are
common that is actionable.
So we mentioned a lot of
different types of cancer from breast cancer,
colon
cancer, skin cancer, prostate cancer -- those
are
the big four.
Except for lung cancer, which we know
is mainly attributed to smoking, that has
much less
of a genetic effect.
So those are all highly
actionable.
If we even learn that a baby is at
risk, we can add preventions throughout life.
For
cardiovascular disease, we've seen this example
with heart attack.
That heart attack analysis where we saw that
person
was close to 70 percent.
That was based on a large
number of genes.
So we're not just looking at one
gene that has a small degree of risk.
We're looking
at a lot of different genes, all of them have
small risks.
But together, when a person has a lot of different
small risks, that adds up and starts to build
upon
itself.
So that does enable us to see very high
risks in people even if they don't have those
rare
conditions.
So even if they have just more common
forms of cholesterol build up and heart attack
risk.
And the same thing with Alzheimer's disease.
So
Alzheimer's disease has stolen the minds of
an
entire generation.
And many of us fear that that
will be our fate.
We can now predict risk of
Alzheimer's disease and we could do that quite
well.
And we can enact preventions.
So there's no way to
stop Alzheimer's disease, but there's ways,
clear ways to
slow it down tremendously from ever occurring
so
that if we just push it back ten years instead
of
affecting a person when they're 75 years,
it starts at 85.
That's a large number of golden years they
have to
live that are healthy instead of sick.
And also with a large amount of money putting
towards research towards pharmaceuticals that
are
working to actually cure diseases like Alzheimer's,
those ten years may be all that a person needs
to
stay healthy until a new medication comes
out.
So
it's buying time for a large number of people.
there are a large number of common diseases.
It
also falls into a spectrum of autoimmune diseases,
blood clotting disorders, a lot of useful
information that unfortunately a lot of people
think
that it's just cystic fibrosis or it's just
Tay-Sach's
disease or it's just the dilated cardiomyopathy
that
I mentioned.
But just recently, it really has
expanded out to include a large number of
actionable
common diseases.
Yes?
>>Female #1: I'm curious to know how static
is a
person's genetic profile as they grow, as
they
age -- does it change or once you've taken
the
profile of a person when they're a baby, does
that
still hold when they're older?
>>Dr. Colby: So the question is, "Does the
genetic
makeup of a person -- the genetic profile
-- does
that change with age?"
So we mentioned the example
of baby Emily.
She had that genetic testing when
she was a baby.
If she had genetic testing again
when she was 50 years old, would that information
change?
Would that raw data change?
And the raw
data -- so the letters themselves -- do not
change.
At the moment of conception on the moment
of
death -- those raw data, those letters -- of
the genetic code
are the same.
Those things around our genes that
turn our genes on and off -- those change.
It's
called the epigenome.
The epigenetics but the raw
data -- what we're able to acquire now with
the DNA
chip with whole genome sequencing -- that
does not
change.
So with whole genome sequencing, if we
sequence a newborn, we get those 6 billion
letters,
they really never need to have a similar type
of
genetic test again.
We have all that data.
It's
all there.
Now it all comes down to analysis and
reporting of that information.
Female #1: The other question is will their
propensity to certain diseases change because
certain markers come on and off based on certain
environmental factors they're dealing with?
>>Dr. Colby: So so the propensity for disease
based
upon just the raw data will not change.
But their
propensity will change because almost all
of these
common diseases -- heart disease, the cancers,
Alzheimer's -- it's not either only genes
or only
environment, it's a combination.
So by learning
about our genetic risks, we're able to modify
our
non-genetic risk factors -- lifestyle, medications,
foods we eat, exercises we do.
So that will change
the total risk.
Now, people though -- let's say a
person goes and smokes -- that will turn on
and off
certain genes that are protecting or increasing
a
person's risk of cancer.
So they can modify if
genes turn on and off, but not the raw data
-- not
those letters themselves.
That is going to stay
the same.
Male #2: My question is around the accuracy
of
genetic testing and actually identifying whether
something that somebody
is predisposed to is going to manifest
itself versus somebody who's not predisposed
to it
genetic testing will come out.
So if you took ten people identified
through tests testing that might have something,
what's the likelihood that they actually end
up showing it
versus ten random people?
>>Dr. Colby: Right.
So the question is about the
accuracy of genetic testing data.
Are these
predictions that are being made -- those risk
predictions -- how accurate are they?
And the
accuracy is really disease dependent -- disease
or
trait dependent.
It differs depending on the amount
of research that's been conducted about those
genes
that are associated with that disease.
So for
diseases like heart attack or diseases like
Alzheimer's, for many types of cancer or even
many
types of autoimmune diseases, the accuracy
is very
high right now.
For other diseases like brain cancer,
pancreatic cancer -- different types of the
rarer
cancers -- the accuracy is quite low.
That we only
have a few markers and is they're not very
predictive.
Now, it's true that over time these
predictions are going to only improve.
That we're
going to learn that there are more genes.
We're
going to integrate that into the analysis.
So the
analysis is going to change.
But that's true of all of
medicine, that there's no component on medicine
that
is locked, that is concrete.
Medicine is always
changing.
It's always evolving.
And genetics and predictive
medicine is no different.
And as an example, CPR
was practiced one way for about 100 years.
And just
recently it came out that that was not the
correct
way.
That it could be done better.
So CPR
guidelines were completely modified.
And now, that
old way is no more.
And we have a new method for
CPR.
So that doesn't mean that CPR -- all the people
who
were performing CPR in the 60s and 70s and
80s
should have never been doing it.
It just means that,
as part of medicine, things are going to improve
and
they're going to get better as new research
comes
out.
That will certainly happen with genetic
testing as well.
>>Female #2: I have a question.
Well, the first
question I wondered is for some of these rare
diseases now that you're able to test people
who
don't suspect they would have a rare disease,
are
you finding that they're more common?
Or is it kind
of upholding the original estimates?
>>Dr. Colby: So we're finding that a lot of
times it is more
common in terms of people who carry those
diseases.
Just because we never before had the ability
to
actually screen for those.
So we're finding that
people do carry some of the more common rare
diseases, like Tay-Sach's or cystic fibrosis.
We're
identifying them then saying, "well, my family
has
never had a case of that.
I had no idea that was in
my genes."
And according to statistics, because all
this was really was just based on statistical
computations in the past in terms of saying,
"well,
this many people have it, so therefore we
could
suspect that this many people probably carry
it,"
but we're finding out that those rates are
a bit
higher now.
>>Female #2: Okay?
>>Dr. Colby: But we're also right at the beginning
of
this.
So we're just unlocking that door on the
number of people with rare diseases.
And
identifying them and counseling them on ways
to
avoid harming future generations.
>>Female #2: Okay.
Thank you.
I guess the last
question then is you've probably sold a bunch
of us
on getting our whole genome mapped.
But what do we
do?
I've talked to my geneticist.
He says, "it's
going to probably cost you a couple thousand
dollars.
Insurance probably won't cover it.
Do you
have any advice for us?"
>>Dr. Colby: So there are two components.
The question
was that you're interested in genetic testing.
You
want to potentially get your whole genome
sequenced.
Where can you go for this?
What's the advice
surrounding having this be actionable now.
So in
terms of genome sequencing, that is still
in the
thousands.
So that's getting all 6 billion letters.
Some individuals are doing that now.
But it's still
really very much in the research realm.
That
they're using it in research participants.
For
people who are true techies that have the
money,
yes they're able to get their whole genome
now.
The
issue is being able to analyze and use that
information rather than just have it be cool
that
you have your whole genome.
So if you are
interested in that, then a lot of geneticists,
doctors, they could go through a company like
Illumina down in San Diego which is an excellent
company that provides sequencing and has done
it before
for clinicians and actually detected some
rare
diseases in children and saved their lives
with
this technology.
There are other companies, too, that
have gone public recently.
Complete Genomics and
Biosciences have also provide that service.
There's
Life Technologies also in San Diego -- provides
Ion
Torrent service.
So there are a lot of services out
there.
Even GE is working on a technology and IBM
as well.
So you Googlers need to get on the
sequencing, too.
So the sequencing is a bit away
off.
I see it as being two years off from when
it's
really cost effective and useful on a clinical
level.
But the DNA chip now is accessible to all
of
you.
So whether it's the Nexus DNA chip which we
make only available through a professional,
whether
it's a fitness trainer or your doctor, or
your
geneticist.
Any doctor around the world can could
you go and order this testing through us.
Or it
could also be -- let's say you prefer to not
go
through a professional -- you could go online
to company
like a company called 23 and Me and you
could order genetic testing as well.
The difference
is you look at the reports, most of these
companies
have sample reports.
You look at the types of
information, at the different types of diseases,
because they don't test all for the same ones.
And
you see what is most important to you.
What you
want to get out of it.
And then, you could decide
what is the best service?
Do you really want a
professional involved?
If so, then that kind of narrows
it down to certain companies that provide
that
service.
Or do you only want to go over the
Internet and just get it personally?
And that also
narrows it down to companies.
Sure.
>>Female #3: Thank you very much.
>>Dr. Colby: Thank you.
[Applause]